so far the photos that have been
released from the detention centers do
not show any girls in them that's
raising a lot of concerns about where
those children are customs officials
released these photos showing boys in a
holding facility the Department of
Health and Human Services has not been
able to tell us or will not tell us
they've been asked repeatedly where the
girls separated from the families are
being sent the Obama administration's
former acting head of Immigration and
Customs Enforcement that's John sand wag
said yesterday that sometimes families
separated the border are never reunited
just think about that and know he says a
parent may be deported before the
child's case goes to an immigration
judge
Matea via al spoke to a public defender
who said he represents immigrants with
no idea still where their children have
been taken they're crying they're
begging they're pleading they're asking
us for all of the obvious questions
which are where where's my daughter or
son how long are they going to be there
how can I help them how are you gonna
help me these are all the questions and
I mean with tears sobbing uncontrollably
and this will go on for over an hour
US Customs and Border Protection says
various government organizations work to
facilitate regular communication between
detained parents and their children but
the question is why aren't these parents
allowed to be with their children
why aren't they allowed to talk with
their children I don't they know where
their children are on top of everything
else and now we have the new report this
morning that essentially according to
one expert that takes care of migrant
that toddlers are being detained yeah
and this is a thing zero tolerance
should not mean zero compassion and when
you sit and talk to these people you
really realize and you can feel the pain
I think you can feel the pain through
the TV screen to be told that you could
possibly not even ever see your child
again makes no sense to me and we're
sitting here watching this happen what
we're seeing is the zero tolerance
policy that's been implemented was
implemented in a way with no preparation
to handle all of these new toddlers and
babies that that they're going to these
places but they don't have the
facilities so it's they're just trying
to catch up with this new policy that's
why we will continue to shine a light on
this story